all right next up on the docket for
today
the colts
confirmed
to the indianapolis star and both the
forbes on wednesday
that there was an offer made to purchase
the team of 3.2 billion dollars and jim
irsay rejected it now they haven't
identified whoever made the offer
and i've got two theories okay i'd like
to hear that all right and i want you to
know which way you land okay first
theory is
because they say the team isn't for sale
that's part of this right rejected 3.2
billion offer the team isn't for sale
first theory the team is for sale and
the floor is 3.2 billion gotcha okay
right second theory and this is kind of
like petty
take out a sharpie theory i got to be
careful but um
that forbes came out yesterday with its
valuation of the franchises at 2.6
billion yeah right right and he hey oh
this team's worth more than 2.6 billion
right somebody offered me 3.2 billion
and i said no even if
that offer was never made yes i could
see
jim irsay doing that because he's pissed
off that he's middle of the pack lower
middle of the pack 2.6 billion here are
the cowboys at 5.5 billion how dare you
my team's worth more than that my team's
worth three point due i'll give you
evidence but i i was offered 3.2 and i
said no yeah so which one do you think
it is
is the team for sale or is he just
trying to pump up the perceived value i
think it's the perceived value of the
team the first thing i thought of was
like was this something like the owners
talked about and like was this like a
coup d'etat to go like no i was offered
3.2 billion yeah we're all worth more
than than what forbes says or whatever
else it is out there i mean i don't know
what's the point of putting this out
there in general that's where i guess if
you're if you want to sell the team for
more than 3.2 billion that's one reason
to put it out the carolina panthers set
their record right 2.3 2.3 billion so
here's he got offered a billion dollars
more 900 million more basically
i i i don't know i just i can't imagine
that that's true i feel like we would
have heard names or somebody along
connected to this situation i feel like
it is a little bit of a maybe a
propaganda to just prop up the franchise
a little bit but i have no idea what
what the deal is here and look the
bottom line is
anything is worth whatever someone will
pay for it if the seller will sell it
and it doesn't like the cowboys they're
worth 5.5 billion we know what jerry
jones is never going to sell that team
for 5.5 billion but the thing to keep in
mind is this as the franchise values go
up and up and up it is going to be
harder and harder for the families that
own these teams to be able to continue
to own them because there's an estate
tax obligation that kicks in when that
equity is handed down so you gotta have
enough extra cash right to pay that
because now you're going to sell part of
the t and some i guess some of you sell
partners yeah some have had to sell all
of the team to pay the estate taxes but
at some point
the values are going to be so high that
there's not going to be enough human
beings with enough money to own the
teams and they're going to have to
figure out whether they drop the minimum
percentage that's required at some point
do they go to corporate ownership i mean
this is down the road but not all that
far down the road because these
franchise values keep going up and up
and up and up yeah well it's the nfl
it's kicking butt and it's just a
money-making machine at this point and
yeah i mean again with new stadiums
teams building new facilities the tv
packages everything that goes along with
it i mean the nfl franchises of course
are king in this country but yeah this
is a little little i was a little
curious to what your thoughts were in
general uh and yeah i i lean i i lean
towards the we're propping it up for my
own benefit of what i think the price of
the team is and and all nfl because
here's the thing if you're out there
with 3.2 billion dollars and you want to
buy a team you don't quietly go to jim
irsay and say i want to buy your team
for 3.2 billion you hold a press
conference and you say i got 3.2 billion
dollars and whoever wants to sell me
their team give me a call that's that's
where i would that's my point when i was
saying i just i have a hard time feeling
we wouldn't have heard a name from a
chef or a mortenson you somebody out
there right including you yeah you're
kind of in their class either way but so
yeah i was i was just shocked usually
you kind of hear little inklings or
rumors about who might be associated
with that type of offer
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports